This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We heard you. The chorus of voices all asking, where is Con Law? Where is Elizabeth Jo to guide us through this madness? We need it now more than ever. Well, here it is. We're bringing the show back with a special extra long episode. Plus, we have an announcement about how the series is going to grow and develop from here. It is very exciting. So let's get into it. Oh my goodness. It is Monday, June 2nd at 10 AM as we record this, what are we going to be talking about today?
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们听到了你们的声音。大家都在齐声询问：宪法法（Con Law）去哪儿了？伊丽莎白·乔（Elizabeth Jo）在哪里引导我们走出这场疯狂？我们现在比以往任何时候都更需要它。好吧，它来了。我们将通过一期特别的超长节目让这个系列回归。此外，我们还有一个关于该系列未来如何成长和发展的公告。这非常令人兴奋。那么，让我们开始吧。天哪，现在是6月2日星期一上午10点，我们正在录制这期节目，今天我们要聊些什么呢？
Well, I thought we'd go back in time and we would start with Zoot Suits. Are you familiar with the Zot suit, Rowan? Very familiar. I love a good zoot suit. It's that big suit jacket with wide lapels, huge shoulder pads, high-waisted, baggy pants that taper toward the bottom. And if you remember the movie Who Framed Roger Rabbit from the 1980s, the Toon Patrol weasels all wore zoot suits. Those were the bad guys. Look, Valiant, we got a reliable tip-off. The rabbit was here and was corrugated by several otters.
嗯，我想我们可以回顾过去，从祖特装（Zoot Suits）开始。罗曼，你熟悉祖特装吗？非常熟悉。我喜欢那种漂亮的祖特装。它有着宽大翻领的西装外套、巨大的垫肩，以及高腰、裤脚收窄的宽松长裤。如果你还记得20世纪80年代的电影《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》，卡通巡逻队的黄鼠狼们都穿着祖特装。那些是坏蛋。听着，瓦利安特，我们得到了可靠的线报。兔子就在这儿，而且被几只水獭围住了。
And the sending of Roger Rabbit takes us to the right period of time, the 1940s. Now, after the United States enters World War II in December of 1941, millions of young men are committed to military service. And on February 19th, 1942, President Roosevelt issued Executive Order 9066. And that's the infamous order that placed people of Japanese ancestry, including US citizens into internment camps. Now both of these wartime actions resulted in a huge labor shortage, especially
而《兔子罗杰》的背景把我们带到了那个特定的时期，即20世纪40年代。在1941年12月美国参加第二次世界大战后，数百万年轻人投身军旅。1942年2月19日，罗斯福总统发布了第9066号行政命令。这就是那项臭名昭著的命令，它将包括美国公民在内的日裔人士关进了拘留营。这两项战时行动都导致了严重的劳动力短缺，尤其是
in agriculture, because so many Japanese Americans had worked on farms. And one major response the federal government provides is to recruit foreign workers from Mexico. And in 1942, in August, the United States signed an agreement with Mexico to create the Mexican Farm Labor Program Agreement. This would formally allow Mexicans to enter the United States to work on a temporary basis. Now, this arrangement is better known as the Bracero Program. Bracero literally means a person who works with their arms, like farm work. And the program would eventually bring millions of Mexican nationals to the United States because it was renewed multiple times.
在农业领域，因为许多日裔美国人曾在农场工作。联邦政府提供的一项主要应对措施是从墨西哥招募外国工人。1942年8月，美国与墨西哥签署了一项协议，创建了“墨西哥农场劳工计划协议”。这正式允许墨西哥人进入美国进行短期工作。这种安排更广为人知的名称是“布拉塞罗计划”（Bracero Program）。“Bracero”字面意思是“用双臂工作的人”，即农场劳工。由于该计划多次续签，最终将数百万墨西哥国民带到了美国。
Now in Los Angeles, this sudden influx of Mexican nationals added to even more problems, and those were the racial tensions brewing in the city. At the time, Mexican Americans were the largest racial minority in Los Angeles. And during World War II, Los Angeles became a major center for military production jobs, and a very large number of military service members are stationed there too. And that draws workers from everywhere and from every background, whites, African Americans, and Mexican Americans. And most of the service members stationed in Los Angeles are white. So you have wartime patriotism, suspicions about not just Japanese Americans, but all non-whites, and zoot suits.
在洛杉矶，墨西哥国民的突然涌入加剧了更多问题，那就是城市中酝酿的种族紧张局势。当时，墨西哥裔美国人是洛杉矶最大的少数族裔。二战期间，洛杉矶成为军事生产工作的主要中心，也有大量军人驻扎在那里。这吸引了来自各地、各种背景的工人，包括白人、非裔美国人和墨西哥裔美国人。驻扎在洛杉矶的军人大多是白人。所以，你既有战时的爱国主义，也有对日裔美国人乃至所有非白人的怀疑，还有祖特装。
And that's where these suits come in. Mexican-American teenagers in Southern California had started to adopt a distinct look. Dangling watch chains, pork pie hats, ducktail hairstyles, and zoot suits. Now, the zoot suit seems pretty tame, right, by 2025 standards. It's actually pretty nice. But in the 1940s, the zoot suit gets a really bad rap. In 1942, the War Production Board issued regulations to allow only streamlined suits to save fabric. A lot of people, including the mostly white service members in Los Angeles, see the zoot
这就是这些西装出现的地方。南加州的墨西哥裔美国青少年开始采用一种独特的装扮。悬挂的表链、猪肉派帽、鸭尾发型和祖特装。以2025年的标准来看，祖特装似乎相当温和，对吧？其实它挺好看的。但在20世纪40年代，祖特装的名声非常糟糕。1942年，战时生产委员会发布规定，为了节省布料，只允许生产流线型西装。许多人，包括洛杉矶大多数白人军人，都认为祖特装
suit as quite literally unpatriotic. It's wasteful. It's illegal. And they called zoot suiters draft dodgers for not joining the military during the war. Now, some young Mexican Americans in LA also formed gangs and adopted zoot suits as their distinctive style, part of what they call the Pachuco subculture. That's how the Zoot Suit became associated with Mexican American gangs, including what's known as the 38th Street Gang.
简直是不爱国。它是浪费的，是非法的。他们称穿祖特装的人为“逃避兵役者”，因为他们在战争期间没有参军。一些洛杉矶的年轻墨西哥裔美国人也组成了帮派，并将祖特装作为他们独特的风格，这是他们所谓的“帕楚科”（Pachuco）亚文化的一部分。这就是祖特装如何与墨西哥裔美国人帮派联系在一起的，包括所谓的“第38街帮”。
Local LA papers announced in the summer of 1942 that the city was experiencing a crime wave by Pachuco Zoot Suit gangsters. And it's against all of this backdrop that on August 2nd, 1942, a 22-year-old Mexican-American man named Jose Diaz was found dead by a reservoir called Sleepy Lagoon just outside of LA. Diaz had attended a party the night before, where a fight had broken out by a group crashing the party. Over the next few days, the LAPD rounded up more than 600 people,
洛杉矶当地报纸在1942年夏天宣布，该市正经历一场由“帕楚科祖特装黑帮”引发的犯罪浪潮。正是在这种背景下，1942年8月2日，一名22岁的墨西哥裔美国男子何塞·迪亚兹（Jose Diaz）被发现死在洛杉矶郊外一个叫“沉睡泻湖”（Sleepy Lagoon）的水库旁。迪亚兹前一天晚上参加了一个聚会，一群不请自来的人在那里引发了斗殴。在接下来的几天里，洛杉矶警察局逮捕了600多人，
mostly Mexican Americans. A grand jury eventually indicted 24 Mexican American men between the ages of 16 and 22. They're described throughout the trial as members of the 38th Street gang. Most of them were tried together in a single trial and 17 of them were convicted of crimes ranging from assault to first degree murder. That resulted in what would be called the Sleepy Lagoon trial of 1942. The evidence was pretty flimsy and the legal proceedings were flawed.
主要是墨西哥裔美国人。大陪审团最终起诉了24名年龄在16至22岁之间的墨西哥裔美国男子。在整个审判过程中，他们被描述为“第38街帮”的成员。他们中的大多数人被合并在同一场审判中受审，其中17人被判犯有从袭击到一级谋杀等罪行。这导致了所谓的1942年“沉睡泻湖审判”。证据相当薄弱，法律程序也存在缺陷。
Over the 13-week trial, the prosecution introduced a number of experts who gave some pretty racist testimony. An LA County Sheriff's Captain named Edward Ayers filed a statement that Mexicans were probably inherently violent, maybe because in his view, most Mexicans were Indian and their Aztec ancestry, which involves human sacrifice, probably gave them a propensity to violence. The trial judge also refused to let the defendants cut their long hair or to change their clothes during the first month of trial. And so the LA Times called the defendants the zoot suit slayers. And the trial today is considered to have been radically unfair.
在为期13周的审判中，检方引入了一些专家，他们提供了相当种族主义的证词。一位名叫爱德华·艾尔斯（Edward Ayers）的洛杉矶县警长队长提交了一份声明，称墨西哥人可能天生暴力，也许是因为在他看来，大多数墨西哥人是印第安人，而他们的阿兹特克祖先涉及人祭，这可能使他们具有暴力倾向。审判法官还拒绝让被告在审判的第一个月剪掉长发或更换衣服。于是《洛杉矶时报》称被告为“祖特装杀手”。今天的审判被认为是非常不公正的。
In 1944, a California appeals court reversed the convictions, finding that the defendants had not received a fair trial. The Sleepy Lagoon case is considered just a precursor to the Zoot Suit riots in the summer of 1943, where white civilians and servicemen roamed the streets of LA looking for Zoot suiters. And it was during those terrible days that Mexican Americans and then African Americans and Filipino Americans were beaten and stripped of their zoot suits for weeks. Local newspapers hailed the fight against what they called foreign criminals. And the violence finally ended when military officials banned service members from traveling to LA who were looking for trouble.
1944年，加州上诉法院推翻了判决，认定被告没有得到公正的审判。沉睡泻湖案被认为是1943年夏天“祖特装暴动”的前奏，当时白人平民和军人在洛杉矶街头游荡，寻找穿祖特装的人。正是在那些可怕的日子里，墨西哥裔美国人，随后是非裔美国人和菲律宾裔美国人，连续几周遭到殴打并被剥去祖特装。当地报纸为打击所谓的“外国罪犯”而欢呼。当军方官员禁止寻找麻烦的军人前往洛杉矶时，暴力事件最终结束了。
The LA City Council even voted to approve a resolution to ban zoot suits. So what do claims to wartime authority, supposed symbols of gang culture, and racism have to do with what's going on now in 2025? I think I have an idea. Time to find out. Let's do it. This is what Trump can teach us about con law. We're not only back, we're going back to the original name.
洛杉矶市议会甚至投票通过了一项禁止祖特装的决议。那么，对战时权力的主张、帮派文化的所谓象征以及种族主义，与2025年的现状有什么关系呢？我想我有个主意。是时候找出答案了。让我们开始吧。这是《特朗普能教我们什么关于宪法法的知识》。我们不仅回来了，我们还要用回原来的名字。
An ongoing series of regular release where we look at what zoot suits and tattoos have in common with Trump's perverted interpretation of the Alien Enemies Act and use it to examine our constitution like we never have before. Our music is from Doomtree Records, our professor and neighbor is Elizabeth Jo, and I'm your fellow student and host, Roman Mars. Oh, and stay tuned to the end of the show for a special announcement that you really do not want to miss. So from that prologue, I assume we're going to talk about the Alien Enemies Act. Yeah, that's where we're going. So let's remind people about what the act does, right? The Alien Enemies Act dates back to the 18th century when Congress passes it and a group
这是一个定期发布的系列节目，我们探讨祖特装和纹身与特朗普对《外籍敌侨法》（Alien Enemies Act）的扭曲解读有什么共同点，并用它来以前所未有的方式审视我们的宪法。我们的音乐来自Doomtree Records，我们的教授和邻居是伊丽莎白·乔，我是你们的同学兼主持人，罗曼·马尔斯。哦，请留心节目结尾，有一个你绝对不想错过的特别公告。那么从序言来看，我假设我们要谈论《外籍敌侨法》。是的，我们要谈的就是这个。那么让我们提醒大家该法案的作用，对吧？《外籍敌侨法》可以追溯到18世纪，当时国会通过了它以及一组
of other laws known as the Alien and Sedition Acts. Only the Alien Enemies Act remains good law today. So Roman, maybe you can read the important part of that law again. Whenever there is a declared war between the United States and any foreign nation or government or any invasion or predatory incursion is perpetrated, attempted, or threatened against the territory of the United States by any foreign nation or government. All natives, citizens, denizens, or subjects of the hostile nation or government shall be liable to be apprehended, restrained, secured, and removed as alien enemies."
其他被称为《客籍法和煽动叛乱法》的法律。如今只有《外籍敌侨法》仍然是有效的法律。所以罗曼，也许你可以再读一遍该法律的重要部分。“每当美国与任何外国或政府之间发生宣战，或者任何外国或政府对美国领土实施、企图或威胁入侵或掠夺性入侵时，敌对国家或政府的所有原住民、公民、居民或臣民均应被逮捕、限制、扣押并作为外籍敌侨予以驱逐。”
That's a mouthful, right? So in plain English, what the act does is to give the president of the United States the power to detain or deport aliens, which is really just the federal law term for non-citizens. And so the act refers to all citizens, denizens, or subjects of a hostile nation or government. So under the Alien Enemies Act, it doesn't matter whether you are a non-citizen lawfully within the United States or not. And the act itself does not guarantee that a person that the president deems an enemy alien will receive notice or a hearing before they're detained or even deported.
这很拗口，对吧？所以用通俗的话说，该法案的作用是赋予美国总统拘留或驱逐外籍人士的权力，这实际上只是联邦法律中对非公民的称呼。因此，该法案指的是敌对国家或政府的所有公民、居民或臣民。所以根据《外籍敌侨法》，你是否是合法居住在美国的非公民并不重要。而且该法案本身并不保证总统认为的敌对外国人在被拘留甚至驱逐之前会收到通知或举行听证会。
And the government doesn't even need to satisfy any standard of proof under the act that you are in fact an enemy alien. So the entire idea behind the act is to give the president of the United States the authority to expel people who are dangerous to national interests during the war. But the intention of the Alien Enemies Act is not as a tool of mass deportation. We have a huge and complex set of federal immigration laws, primarily under the Immigration and Nationality Act, that spell out how undocumented people in the United States are to be treated, what legal recourse they have, and what the government's rights and responsibilities
而且根据该法案，政府甚至不需要满足任何证明标准来证明你实际上是敌对外国人。因此，该法案背后的整个理念是赋予美国总统在战争期间驱逐对国家利益构成危险的人的权力。但《外籍敌侨法》的初衷并不是作为大规模驱逐的工具。我们有一套庞大而复杂的联邦移民法，主要是在《移民与国籍法》之下，规定了如何对待美国境内的无证人员，他们有什么法律追索权，以及政府的权利和责任
are. Now, you and I both talked about the Alien Enemies Act at the end of last year, because Trump, as a presidential candidate, kept promising to rely on the Alien Enemies Act as a way to begin mass deportations of what he'd usually refer to as illegal criminal migrants. Now remember, there was a big part of his platform, right, for the 2024 election where he kept saying there's this huge migrant crime wave that he alone would stop. And then we talked about it because the act seemed like an interesting theoretical problem. You know, Trump couldn't possibly invoke
是什么。现在，你和我去年年底都谈到了《外籍敌侨法》，因为特朗普作为总统候选人，一直承诺依靠《外籍敌侨法》作为开始大规模驱逐他通常所说的“非法犯罪移民”的一种方式。现在记住，这是他2024年竞选纲领的一个重要部分，对吧？他一直说存在一场巨大的移民犯罪浪潮，只有他能阻止。然后我们讨论了它，因为该法案看起来像是一个有趣的理论问题。你知道，特朗普不可能援引
the Alien Enemies Act, right? That was just like a crazy threat. There was no way he was gonna do it, right? Yeah, I mean, or like I believed in his belief to make that threat and that the horrible people around him would want to do that, but that there was something in the Constitution that would stop him from doing these things. Yeah.
《外籍敌侨法》，对吧？那只是一个疯狂的威胁。他不可能真的这么做，对吧？是的，我的意思是，或者像我一样相信他有做出这种威胁的信念，而且他周围那些可怕的人会想这么做，但宪法中有什么东西会阻止他做这些事情。是的。
Well, he went ahead and did it. There were so many different crazy, outrageous, and sometimes clearly illegal things that have happened during the past five months, plus hundreds of lawsuits at this point, that it's sort of hard to keep up with what's happened. But I think it's important here for us to at least focus on what's happened with this mass deportation scheme, all right? Yeah. So as soon as Trump began his second term,
好吧，他真的这么做了。在过去的五个月里，发生了太多疯狂、令人发指且有时显然是非法的事情，加上此时此刻数百起诉讼，很难跟上发生了什么。但我认为在这里我们至少关注一下这个大规模驱逐计划发生了什么，好吗？好的。所以特朗普一进入他的第二个任期，
he issued an enormous number of executive orders. Remember, he's not a new president anymore, and this time his administration is prepared to act as soon as he takes office. Now keep in mind that when a president issues an executive order, they are not the same as Congress passing a law. They don't have the same legal status. So these executive orders that we're going to talk about focus on immigration. Some of these executive orders rescind or cancel Biden era policies. One is a Biden era policy that says ICE should focus on immigration enforcement on people who pose a public safety threat.
他就发布了大量的行政命令。记住，他不再是一个新总统了，这一次他的政府准备在他上任后立即采取行动。现在请记住，当总统发布行政命令时，它们与国会通过的法律是不一样的。它们没有相同的法律地位。所以我们要讨论的这些行政命令侧重于移民。其中一些行政命令废除或取消了拜登时代的政策。一个是拜登时代的政策，即移民与海关执法局（ICE）应将移民执法重点放在对公共安全构成威胁的人身上。
In other words, if they're not posing a public safety threat, don't try to find and arrest these people. That was a Biden policy. Another Biden immigration policy is no enforcement in what are called sensitive places like churches, schools, hospitals, and Trump gets rid of that too. So the result is that immigration enforcement now is something that can happen to any undocumented person anywhere. Doesn't matter whether you've been here for a week or a decade or almost your whole life. It doesn't matter whether you have a criminal record or not. It doesn't matter whether you've been here for a week or a decade or almost your whole life. It doesn't matter whether you have a criminal record or not.
换句话说，如果他们不构成公共安全威胁，就不要试图寻找和逮捕这些人。那是拜登的政策。另一个拜登的移民政策是在所谓的敏感地点（如教堂、学校、医院）不进行执法，特朗普也废除了这一点。所以结果是，移民执法现在可以发生在任何地方的任何无证人员身上。无论你是在这里待了一周、十年还是几乎一辈子，这都不重要。无论你是否有犯罪记录，这都不重要。无论你是在送孩子上学还是去看医生，这都不重要。任何无证人员现在都是逮捕和拘留的潜在目标。
It doesn't matter whether you're taking your kid to school or going to the doctor. Anybody who is undocumented is now a potential target for arrest and detention. So on January 20th, remember this is the first day of Trump's second term, Trump issues a proclamation that the United States is experiencing an invasion by illegal aliens.
所以1月20日，记住这是特朗普第二个任期的第一天，特朗普发布公告称美国正在经历一场非法外籍人士的入侵。
The word invasion is important and it's deliberate here. And then ICE agents begin a surge of raids and large scale arrests around the country. The number of people detained by ICE appears to have gone up dramatically since Trump took office, including the percentage of people detained by ICE appears to have gone up dramatically since Trump took office, including the percentage of people with no criminal history. And this is all happening because the Trump administration reportedly has a goal of deporting
“入侵”这个词很重要，在这里是经过深思熟虑的。然后ICE特工开始在全国范围内进行突袭和大规模逮捕。自特朗普上任以来，被ICE拘留的人数似乎急剧上升，包括没有犯罪记录的人的比例。而这一切之所以发生，是因为据报道，特朗普政府的目标是在一年内驱逐
a million people within a year. That is a huge number, larger than has ever been accomplished by any other president in any other term. But when you have such a huge number, that means that there is pressure on the Department of Homeland Security to find people, any people who could be deported. And Stephen Miller recently said on Fox that the goal is to complete 3,000 ICE arrests every single day. So that's really a quota.
一百万人。这是一个巨大的数字，比任何其他总统在任何其他任期内完成的都要多。但当你拥有如此庞大的数字时，这意味着国土安全部面临着寻找可以被驱逐的人的压力，任何人都可以。斯蒂芬·米勒（Stephen Miller）最近在福克斯新闻上说，目标是每天完成3000次ICE逮捕。所以这确实是一个配额。
So to put this in terms that they're easy to understand, you know Imagine like your local police department. The police chief says look we have a new quota and every officer has to issue Ten tickets on each shift. Well, you know if you're gonna do that and you've got to make your quota You're gonna find people to give tickets to whether it's like, you know, it could be totally indiscriminate, it could be abusive, it doesn't matter, you're just going to hit that quota. That's right. And that's why you're seeing videos of ICE raids of restaurant workers, construction workers, people who aren't really doing anything wrong, but they're really easy to find because they're in plain sight living their lives.
所以用容易理解的话来说，你知道，想象一下你当地的警察局。警察局长说，看，我们有一个新的配额，每个警官在每个班次都必须开出十张罚单。好吧，你知道，如果你要这样做并且必须完成你的配额，你就会找到人来开罚单，无论它是完全不加区别的，还是滥用的，这都不重要，你只是要达到那个配额。没错。这就是为什么你会看到ICE突袭餐馆工人、建筑工人的视频，这些人并没有真正做错什么，但他们很容易被找到，因为他们就在众目睽睽之下过着自己的生活。
Right? Now, some of these people who are either arrested by ICE or questioned during applications for asylum, so legitimately seeking asylum, they received special attention. According to ICE, that was because of their tattoos and their clothing that signaled gang membership. Now, even if we accept that some tattoos are in fact linked to gang membership and even violent gangs, a lot of cases are not like that. There's the instance of a man who was detained by ICE with a tattoo of a crown over a soccer ball. He was a former
对吧？现在，其中一些被ICE逮捕或在申请庇护期间受到盘问的人，即合法寻求庇护的人，受到了特别关注。据ICE称，这是因为他们的纹身和服装标志着帮派成员身份。现在，即使我们承认一些纹身确实与帮派成员身份甚至暴力帮派有关，很多情况并非如此。有一个人被ICE拘留的例子，他有一个足球上方的皇冠纹身。他曾是一名
professional soccer player. That's why he has that tattoo. The clock-shaped tattoo of a man who was celebrating his child's birthday. Another man's tattoos that say mom and dad, and then maybe the absolute worst, a man who was deported for his tattoo, which was a rainbow colored ribbon. That's the symbol of autism awareness for his brother. So these men were Venezuelan nationals. And in March, the Department of Homeland Security started to move these particular detained men from ICE centers around the country and sending most of them to a detention facility in South Texas. And many of the lawyers for these detained individuals thought something was about to happen and they were right. On March 14th, Trump signed proclamation 10903 and it says that Tren de Aragua is a designated foreign terrorist organization with thousands
职业足球运动员。这就是他有那个纹身的原因。还有一个庆祝孩子生日的男人的时钟形状纹身。另一个人的纹身写着“妈妈和爸爸”，然后也许是最糟糕的，一个男人因为他的纹身被驱逐出境，那是一个彩虹色的丝带。那是他兄弟的自闭症意识标志。所以这些人是委内瑞拉国民。3月，国土安全部开始将这些特定的被拘留男子从全国各地的ICE中心转移，并将他们中的大多数人送到德克萨斯州南部的一个拘留设施。这些被拘留者的许多律师认为即将发生什么事情，他们是对的。3月14日，特朗普签署了第10903号公告，称“Tren de Aragua”（TDA）是一个指定的外国恐怖组织，拥有数千名
of members, many of whom have unlawfully infiltrated the United States. Okay. But here's the important part. Roman, why don't you read it? Roman Bocciini, PhD, PhD, UGA, UGA, UGA Okay. So this is quoting Trump. Right.
成员，其中许多人已经非法渗透到美国。好的。但这是重要的部分。罗曼，你为什么不读一下？罗曼·博奇尼，博士，UGA，UGA，UGA 好的。所以这是引用特朗普的话。没错。
I find and declare that TDA is perpetuating, attempting, and threatening an invasion or predatory incursion against the territory of the United States. TDA is undertaking hostile actions and conducting irregular warfare against the territory of the United States, both directly and at the direction of the Maduro regime in Venezuela. Now, the proclamation goes on to say
“我认定并宣布，TDA正在实施、企图和威胁对美国领土进行入侵或掠夺性入侵。TDA正在采取敌对行动，并对美国领土进行非正规战争，既直接进行，也受委内瑞拉马杜罗政权的指使。” 现在，该公告继续说
that all Venezuelan citizens 14 years of age or older who are members of TDA and are not actually naturalized or lawful permanent residents of the United States are liable to be apprehended, restrained, secured and removed as alien enemies. What this means is that the Trump administration is claiming the power to remove Venezuelan non-citizens if they claim that the people they have detained in their custody are members of the TDA gang. So Roman, let's play, what do you think sounds weird about this invocation of the Alien Enemies Act? Well, I don't know, it sounds weird. It sounds like Trump's natural language. But the invasion or predatory incursion seems like a somewhat unnatural, but you can tell completely lifted straight from the Alien Enemies Act.
所有14岁或以上的委内瑞拉公民，如果是TDA成员，且不是美国的归化公民或合法永久居民，均应被逮捕、限制、扣押并作为外籍敌侨予以驱逐。这意味着特朗普政府声称有权驱逐委内瑞拉非公民，如果他们声称他们拘留的人是TDA帮派的成员。所以罗曼，让我们玩个游戏，你觉得这次援引《外籍敌侨法》有什么奇怪的地方？嗯，我不知道，这听起来很奇怪。这听起来像是特朗普的自然语言。但“入侵或掠夺性入侵”听起来有点不自然，但你可以看出完全是直接从《外籍敌侨法》中照搬过来的。
Right. And also the target of the act is TDA, which is a gang. And the last time I checked, if you look at the Alien Enemies Act, this is about countries that we're at war with. Right. And we are not at war with Venezuela. Right. Right.
没错。而且该法案的目标是TDA，这是一个帮派。我上次检查时，如果你看《外籍敌侨法》，这是关于我们处于战争状态的国家。没错。而我们并没有与委内瑞拉处于战争状态。没错。没错。
I mean, there's lots of things that are missing. The things that are shared are the invasion and predatory incursion sort of language, but obviously declared war between the United States. That didn't happen. And then any foreign nation or government and NTDA is neither of those things. Yeah, so the logic here is something like, yes, sure, this gang is not a foreign nation, but they're somehow so intertwined
我的意思是，有很多东西缺失了。共享的东西是“入侵和掠夺性入侵”之类的语言，但显然美国之间没有宣战。这没有发生。然后是任何外国或政府，而TDA两者都不是。是的，所以这里的逻辑是这样的，是的，当然，这个帮派不是一个外国，但他们不知何故与委内瑞拉政府纠缠在一起
with the government of Venezuela, which nobody really believes, that they are treated as if they are a foreign nation. Now, there's clearly no war that Congress has declared here. And so Trump is relying on the other provision of the Alien Enemies Act to say, well, this gang has engaged in a predatory incursion, which most of the time, traditionally, we have interpreted as saying, well, that's a military campaign against the United States. And there's no sense that there is some concerted military invasion by this particular gang. Now, definitely the gang exists, but somehow the Trump administration has decided to shoehorn
——没人真正相信这一点——以至于他们被当作外国来对待。现在，国会显然没有在这里宣战。所以特朗普依靠《外籍敌侨法》的另一项条款说，好吧，这个帮派进行了掠夺性入侵，这在大多数时候，传统上，我们将其解释为，好吧，那是针对美国的军事行动。而且没有任何迹象表明这个特定的帮派有某种协同的军事入侵。现在，帮派确实存在，但特朗普政府不知何故决定将
this gang's activities into a wartime act. And that's really striking because before 2025, the Alien Enemies Act has been used by presidents only three times in the past, the War of 1812, World War I, and World War II. So in 2025, Trump issues a proclamation under the Alien Enemies Act and then starts to act very, very quickly. So quickly, in fact, that the timeline of what happened is actually kind of hard to keep up with. But you ready?
这个帮派的活动强行塞进一项战时法案中。这真的很引人注目，因为在2025年之前，《外籍敌侨法》在过去只被总统使用过三次：1812年战争、第一次世界大战和第二次世界大战。所以2025年，特朗普根据《外籍敌侨法》发布了一份公告，然后开始非常、非常迅速地采取行动。事实上太快了，以至于发生的时间线实际上有点难以跟上。但你准备好了吗？
Yeah, shoot. So there are already several lawsuits over this use of the Alien Enemies Act. So let's just focus on a few, right? One is a lawsuit filed as a class action, arguing that the Alien Enemies Act does not allow the Trump administration to detain and deport non-citizens this way. The ACLU filed a lawsuit the day after Trump signed the proclamation on Saturday, March 15th. And they sue on behalf of five Venezuelan men who are already in ICE detention.
是的，说吧。所以已经有几起关于使用《外籍敌侨法》的诉讼。所以让我们只关注几个，好吗？一个是作为集体诉讼提起的诉讼，辩称《外籍敌侨法》不允许特朗普政府以这种方式拘留和驱逐非公民。美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）在特朗普签署公告后的第二天，即3月15日星期六提起诉讼。他们代表五名已经在ICE拘留中的委内瑞拉男子提起诉讼。
The administration had at this point more than 200 people that it was trying to forcibly expel from the country using the Alien Enemies Act. Now the judge in this case ordered the Trump administration to stop, don't remove these people from the country, subject to the Alien Enemies Act. But here's what the administration does. They delay the deportation of the five people named in the lawsuit, but then they continue with three flights full of people that they have in custody. So here's that crazy timeline.
此时政府有200多人，它正试图利用《外籍敌侨法》将他们强行驱逐出境。现在，此案的法官命令特朗普政府停止，不要根据《外籍敌侨法》将这些人从该国驱逐出去。但政府是这样做的：他们推迟了诉讼中提到的五个人的驱逐，但随后继续执行了三架载满他们拘留的人的飞机。所以这就是那个疯狂的时间线。
Two planes leave the United States between 5 and 6 p.m. on March 16th from a Texas detention facility. On 6 48 p.m. the very same day, the judge tells the government, turn the planes around. He tells the government's lawyer, you shall inform your clients of this immediately and that any plane containing these folks that is going to take off or is in the air needs to be returned to the United States. They do not turn around. And in fact, after this happens, the government flies a third plane from Texas at 7.36 PM the same day.
3月16日下午5点到6点之间，两架飞机从德克萨斯州的一个拘留设施离开美国。同一天下午6点48分，法官告诉政府，让飞机掉头。他告诉政府的律师，你应立即通知你的客户，任何载有这些人且即将起飞或正在空中的飞机都需要返回美国。他们没有掉头。事实上，在这件事发生后，政府在同一天晚上7点36分从德克萨斯州飞出了第三架飞机。
And the reason why these lawyers are rushing to court because the Trump administration is flying these detainees to CICOT. And what is CICOT? Well, CICOT is also known as the Terrorism Confinement Center. It's a giant mega prison outside of the capital of El Salvador. Now, Naib Bukele is the authoritarian president of El Salvador. I mean, by his own admission, he calls himself a really cool dictator. So he has suspended normal due process rights in the country by declaring an ongoing state of emergency. And Bukele has focused on cracking down on criminal gangs
而这些律师之所以急于上法庭，是因为特朗普政府正将这些被拘留者飞往CICOT。什么是CICOT？好吧，CICOT也被称为“恐怖主义监禁中心”。它是萨尔瓦多首都外的一个巨大的超级监狱。现在，纳伊布·布克尔（Naib Bukele）是萨尔瓦多的独裁总统。我的意思是，按照他自己的承认，他称自己为“一个非常酷的独裁者”。所以他通过宣布持续的紧急状态，暂停了该国正常的正当程序权利。布克尔专注于打击犯罪帮派
in El Salvador by putting them into this scary, gigantic prison where tens of thousands of inmates are locked up basically all day long, 23 hours a day, and are basically kept in extreme isolation. The pictures that have been posted are really horrific. There are dozens of men sitting on quadruple bunks, no mattresses, people in chains. And human rights organizations have said that the conditions inside are terrible and that treatment of inmates is abusive.
在萨尔瓦多，将他们关进这个可怕的、巨大的监狱里，成千上万的囚犯基本上整天被关在那里，每天23小时，基本上被保持在极端的隔离状态。张贴出来的照片真的很恐怖。有几十个男人坐在四层铺位上，没有床垫，人们戴着镣铐。人权组织表示，里面的条件很糟糕，对囚犯的待遇是虐待性的。
But it's to Seacott that the Trump administration has chosen to send people they claim are alien enemies. And on March 16th, Carolyn Levitt, the White House press secretary, she acknowledged that the Trump administration is paying El Salvador $6 million to detain people. So El Salvador is acting like a prison subcontractor for the Trump administration. Yeah, but didn't the judge tell the government specifically not to do this?
但特朗普政府选择将他们声称是“外籍敌侨”的人送到Seacott。3月16日，白宫新闻秘书卡罗琳·莱维特（Carolyn Levitt）承认，特朗普政府正在向萨尔瓦多支付600万美元来拘留这些人。所以萨尔瓦多正在充当特朗普政府的监狱分包商。是的，但法官不是明确告诉政府不要这样做吗？
Yeah, and that's where things take a really scary turn. The Trump administration did not turn the planes around after the judge ordered them to do so. And in fact, as I just mentioned, they threw a third plane after the judge posted this official order. Now, the very next day, that's on March 17th, Tom Homan, that's Trump's border czar, he goes on Fox News.
是的，这就是事情变得非常可怕的地方。法官下令后，特朗普政府并没有让飞机掉头。事实上，正如我刚才提到的，在法官发布这份正式命令后，他们又扔出了第三架飞机。现在，就在第二天，即3月17日，汤姆·霍曼（Tom Homan），那是特朗普的边境沙皇，他上了福克斯新闻。
Here's what Homan says, I don't care what judges think. The plane is already over international waters with a plane full of terrorists and significant public safety threats. So think about that. If Homan's right, it's being over international waters that matters. If the government can get non-citizens or maybe anybody over into international waters, then your claims are invalid. No court can help you, period.
霍曼是这样说的：“我不在乎法官怎么想。飞机已经在国际水域上空，载满了恐怖分子和重大的公共安全威胁。” 所以想想看。如果霍曼是对的，那么在国际水域上空就很重要。如果政府能让非公民或者也许任何人进入国际水域，那么你的主张就无效了。没有法院能帮助你，句号。
That's a terrifying argument that all the government has to do is get you beyond the geographic scope of the United States and your toast. Yeah, that is terrifying to me. I mean, it seems like it's a remuneration of the rendition sort of stuff that happened, you know, 20-something years ago. Right. I mean, it's absolutely terrifying. So in court, the Trump administration then appeals this court order, the one that they didn't follow, that hauls any deportations under the Alien Enemies Act. And this eventually gets to the Supreme Court's emergency
这是一个可怕的论点，即政府所要做的就是把你带到美国地理范围之外，你就完蛋了。是的，这对我来说很可怕。我的意思是，这看起来像是20多年前发生的“引渡”之类的东西的重演。没错。我的意思是，这绝对是可怕的。所以在法庭上，特朗普政府随后对这一法院命令提出上诉——他们没有遵守的那一个——该命令暂停了根据《外籍敌侨法》进行的所有驱逐。这最终到达了最高法院的紧急
docket. And on April 7, the Supreme Court issues a short opinion that does two things. The first one looks like a win for the Trump administration. Basically, well, plaintiffs, you filed in the wrong court. You should bring the case where you're being held, not in Washington, DC. So maybe that seems like a loss.
案卷。4月7日，最高法院发布了一份简短的意见，做了两件事。第一件事看起来像是特朗普政府的胜利。基本上，好吧，原告，你们在错误的法院提起诉讼。你们应该在你们被关押的地方提起诉讼，而不是在华盛顿特区。所以也许这看起来像是一次失败。
But the other thing the Supreme Court says is that the government does have to give people detained under the Alien Enemies Act some notice and a reasonable chance to challenge their detention in court. In other words, the Supreme Court acknowledges that these non-citizens do have constitutional due process rights.
但最高法院说的另一件事是，政府确实必须给根据《外籍敌侨法》拘留的人一些通知和合理的挑战拘留的机会。换句话说，最高法院承认这些非公民确实拥有宪法正当程序权利。
And so the court's intervention here does kind of slow down the case for the plaintiffs, which is called JGG versus Trump, but it's not a complete Trump victory either. The court's not going to allow the government to do these middle of the night deportations. Now that's just one lawsuit. Here's the other significant one. A second lawsuit is filed by two detainees whom the government claims are members of TDA. It's called AARP versus Trump, not the American Association of Attire Persons.
所以法院在这里的干预确实减缓了原告的案件，即所谓的“JGG诉特朗普案”，但这也不是特朗普的完全胜利。法院不会允许政府进行这些半夜的驱逐。现在那只是一个诉讼。这是另一个重要的诉讼。第二个诉讼由两名被拘留者提起，政府声称他们是TDA成员。它被称为“AARP诉特朗普案”，不是那个“美国退休人员协会”。
I mean, getting them out of mail I get from the AARP, I'm ready to classify them as a terrorist organization. Yeah, same here. They're also filing on behalf of all detainees in the same situation, right? So like the first case, these plaintiffs file what's called a habeas petition. That's a legal claim that they're being held unlawfully by the government. So at first they ask a federal court to stop the government from deporting them. On April 18th, the detainees in the ARP case file an emergency motion.
我的意思是，收到我从AARP收到的邮件，我准备把他们归类为恐怖组织。是的，我也是。他们也代表处于同样情况的所有被拘留者提起诉讼，对吧？所以像第一个案件一样，这些原告提交了所谓的“人身保护令申请”。这是一种法律主张，即他们被政府非法关押。所以起初他们要求联邦法院阻止政府驱逐他们。4月18日，AARP案中的被拘留者提交了一项紧急动议。
They argue that the federal government is literally about to deport them under the Alien Enemies Act. And they've given them notices about their imminent deportation in English, which the detainees cannot read, it's not their first language, and that the deportation is about to happen in the next 24 hours. Now remember, the Supreme Court had already said in the other case, more than a week before this emergency request, that the government has to provide these detained individuals with some opportunity to challenge their detention. And yet the government's still not really listening. And this helps
他们辩称，联邦政府确实即将根据《外籍敌侨法》驱逐他们。他们用英语给了他们关于即将被驱逐的通知，而这些被拘留者无法阅读，这不是他们的第一语言，而且驱逐将在未来24小时内发生。现在记住，最高法院在这次紧急请求前一周多已经在另一个案件中表示，政府必须为这些被拘留的个人提供一些挑战拘留的机会。然而政府仍然没有真正听取。这有助于
you understand why the Supreme Court does not wait so long this time. On Saturday, April 19th, the Supreme Court issues a stay or a halt at 1252 a.m. to the government, ordering the government not to deport these plaintiffs while their lawsuit is pending. And so, describe to me how unusual is that for them to issue an order at 1252 a.m.? Because that strikes me as extremely unusual. Yeah, it is totally, I mean, I wouldn't say it's totally unprecedented, but it's very, very unusual. Remember that in the first case, the Supreme Court had already said to the Trump administration, you can't just kidnap these non-citizens and then send them to this foreign mega prison.
你理解为什么最高法院这次没有等那么久。4月19日星期六，最高法院在凌晨12点52分发布了暂缓令或停止令，命令政府在诉讼悬而未决期间不要驱逐这些原告。所以，向我描述一下，他们凌晨12点52分发布命令有多不寻常？因为这对我来说极其不寻常。是的，这完全是，我的意思是，我不会说它完全没有先例，但它非常、非常不寻常。记住，在第一个案件中，最高法院已经对特朗普政府说，你不能仅仅绑架这些非公民，然后把他们送到这个外国超级监狱。
And yet the government is apparently in the process of moving the detainees in this second case from a detention center to the airport in violation of the limits the Supreme Court had already issued in the first case on April 7th. So this case bounces up and down the court system for different procedural reasons and goes back to the Supreme Court. On May 16th, the Supreme Court takes another look at the case and basically says, no, really, we really mean it. You cannot put these detainees on planes while their cases are pending.
然而，政府显然正在将第二个案件中的被拘留者从拘留中心转移到机场，这违反了最高法院在4月7日的第一个案件中已经发布的限制。所以这个案件因为不同的程序原因在法院系统中上下跳动，并回到了最高法院。5月16日，最高法院再次审视了这个案件，基本上说，不，真的，我们是认真的。在案件悬而未决期间，你不能把这些被拘留者送上飞机。
If the government wants to deport these detainees, the government has to provide them with notice and in a way that actually allows them to challenge their detention in court. It's definitely not good enough to wave a piece of paper in front of a detainee in a language that they can't read because it's not their first language as they board the plane to El Salvador. And here again, the court makes very clear that even non-citizens are entitled to constitutionally adequate procedures before they're removed from the country. And so this part's important because even though the Alien Enemies Act itself, that
如果政府想驱逐这些被拘留者，政府必须向他们提供通知，并且以一种真正允许他们在法庭上挑战拘留的方式。在他们登上飞往萨尔瓦多的飞机时，在被拘留者面前挥舞一张他们看不懂的语言的纸，这绝对是不够的。在这里，法院再次非常明确地表示，即使是非公民，在被驱逐出境之前也有权获得宪法上充分的程序。所以这部分很重要，因为即使《外籍敌侨法》本身，那
18th century law doesn't state that you should have some way of challenging the government's claims against you. The Supreme Court is saying, look, that doesn't matter because we have this separate set of constitutional traditions that we've developed over the decades saying that if you have what's called a liberty interest, your ability to be in the United States, if you have the right to be there, that we should have or we should grant you some regular procedures, even to non-citizens, before the government removes you from the country. And we are re-emphasizing that these detainees have those rights.
18世纪的法律并没有说明你应该有某种方式来挑战政府对你的指控。最高法院说，看，这不重要，因为我们有这套独立的宪法传统，我们在几十年里发展起来，说如果你有所谓的“自由利益”，你在美国的生存能力，如果你有权在那里，我们应该有或者我们应该授予你一些常规程序，即使是对非公民，在政府将你驱逐出境之前。我们正在重新强调这些被拘留者拥有这些权利。
And that is a principle that's been recognized by the court for more than 100 years. If you're going to just simply deport someone, you can't just deport them. They have a right to some kind of procedure. So there's another interesting part in this decision in the ARP case. The Supreme Court seems to be squarely questioning, finally, the good faith of the Trump administration. The Supreme Court points out the absurdity of the government's position, which is basically, sure, we'll keep these people here on April 18, because we'll have a nighttime court hearing, but that's enough process and
这是一个被法院承认了100多年的原则。如果你要简单地驱逐某人，你不能仅仅驱逐他们。他们有权获得某种程序。所以AARP案的判决中还有另一个有趣的部分。最高法院似乎终于在直接质疑特朗普政府的诚意。最高法院指出了政府立场的荒谬性，基本上是，当然，我们会把这些人留在4月18日，因为我们会进行夜间法庭听证会，但这足以作为程序，
we'll put them on the plane the next day. And it's also the government's position, the Supreme Court points out, that once they're out of the United States, the government no longer has any custody over them. And so the court can't order the government to do anything. That's the Tom Homan, you know, you're an international waters argument. That position is really shocking for the government to take in front of the Supreme Court. Remember, because the Trump administration is paying El Salvador to confine these detainees. If the government paid a private prison in
然后我们第二天就把他们送上飞机。而且政府的立场也是——最高法院指出——一旦他们离开美国，政府就不再对他们有任何监护权。所以法院不能命令政府做任何事情。这就是汤姆·霍曼的“你在国际水域”的论点。政府在最高法院面前采取这种立场真的很令人震惊。记住，因为特朗普政府正在向萨尔瓦多支付费用来监禁这些被拘留者。如果政府向美国的一家私人监狱支付费用
the United States to detain people, we wouldn't expect the United States to be able to argue, well, it's not our problem anymore what this private prison does to these people because it's out of our hands. It doesn't make sense. It's absurd. So of course they are effectively constructively within the custody of the Trump administration still. So you see here in this particular case, the court is in its Supreme Court-ish kind of
来拘留人，我们不会期望美国能够辩称，好吧，这家私人监狱对这些人做什么已经不是我们的问题了，因为它不在我们的控制之下。这说不通。这是荒谬的。所以当然，他们实际上仍然在特朗普政府的有效监护之下。所以你在这里看到这个特定的案件，法院正处于其最高法院式的某种
way being fed up with what the government's saying. Right. Right, right. But does it matter? Let's hope it does matter, because the Supreme Court has decided to step in a couple of times so far, and probably will continue to. We'll be right back. We're back with Professor Elizabeth Jo
对政府的言论感到厌倦。没错。对，没错。但这重要吗？让我们希望这很重要，因为最高法院到目前为止已经决定介入了几次，而且很可能会继续介入。我们马上回来。我们请回了伊丽莎白·乔教授
talking about the Alien Enemies Act. And so Elizabeth, we've been talking about how the Supreme Court has intervened in specific cases that have to do with the rapid rate at which the Trump administration is processing these people for deportation, that people haven't had a chance to petition their cases. But beyond that, is there an indication that the Supreme Court has weighed in on whether or not Trump can use the Alien Enemies Act in this way at all, like in the broad sense? That's a great question. And it's important to know that the Supreme Court has not yet decided that case as to
谈论《外籍敌侨法》。那么伊丽莎白，我们一直在讨论最高法院是如何干预那些与特朗普政府驱逐这些人的速度过快有关的具体案件的，即这些人还没有机会为自己的案件进行申诉。但除此之外，是否有迹象表明最高法院已经权衡了特朗普是否可以以这种方式使用《外籍敌侨法》，比如从广义上来说？这是一个很好的问题。重要的是要知道，最高法院尚未就该案件做出裁决，即
whether or not Trump is actually allowed to rely on the Alien Enemies Act in this particular way. You know, the way courts work is they can only answer the questions that are given to them. They can't step away from this case and be like, by the way, nobody asked us, but this is unconstitutional. So that's right, we were in these kind of emergency procedures because the most immediate thing
特朗普是否真的被允许以这种特定方式依赖《外籍敌侨法》。你知道，法院的工作方式是他们只能回答提交给他们的问题。他们不能脱离这个案件说，顺便说一句，虽然没人问我们，但这违宪。所以没错，我们处于这种紧急程序中，因为最紧迫的事情是
these detainees' lawyers are saying is, please stop them from putting them on the planes and sending them to El Salvador. Now, the underlying claims they have are things like the Trump administration cannot rely on the act in this way. But the Supreme Court has yet to rule on that case. So you have these things. And then the Supreme Court then, of course, in this ARP case says, you know, you can't do this. You got to give them some process. So just a few days later, Trump responds online in a Truth Social post on April 21st, I'm
这些被拘留者的律师们说的是，请阻止他们把这些人送上飞机并送往萨尔瓦多。现在，他们提出的根本主张是，特朗普政府不能以这种方式依赖该法案。但最高法院尚未对该案做出裁决。所以你有这些事情。然后最高法院当然在这次ARP案件中说，你知道，你不能这样做。你必须给他们一些程序。所以就在几天后，特朗普在4月21日的“真实社交”帖子中回应说，我
doing what I was elected to do, remove criminals from our country. And he says, we can't give them due process because, and I quote, that would take without exaggeration 200 years. Well, that is an exaggeration. It would not take 200 years. Well, that is an exaggeration. It would not take 200 years. And yes, that's kind of the point of due process that no matter how long it drags out or how costly it is, that's why we live in a constitutional republic, right? Because we have these kinds of protections. So I mean, that is a big reveal, right, of the kind of framework of the Trump perspective,
正在做我被选出来要做的事，把罪犯从我们的国家清除出去。他说，我们不能给他们正当程序，因为，我引用一下，那将需要，毫不夸张地说，200年。好吧，那是一种夸张。那不会需要200年。好吧，那是一种夸张。那不会需要200年。是的，这正是正当程序的意义所在，无论它拖延多久或成本多高，这就是我们生活在宪政共和国的原因，对吧？因为我们有这些保护措施。所以我的意思是，这是一个重大的揭露，对吧，关于特朗普视角下的框架，
which is, why would we care about doing this? Why would we give any process to these people who cares what our constitutional protections are? So a big part of what makes all of this so very confusing, I think, to people trying to follow along is that there are several different questions about what the government's doing here. So more than 200 people have been sent
那就是，我们为什么要关心这样做？我们为什么要给这些人任何程序？谁在乎我们的宪法保护是什么？所以，我认为让所有这些对试图跟进的人来说如此令人困惑的一个重要部分是，关于政府在这里所做的事情有几个不同的问题。所以已经有超过200人被
by the Trump administration to Seacot in El Salvador so far. Some were sent there because an immigration judge had already considered those folks subject to deportation under normal federal immigration law. And the government certainly can deport a non-citizen, for instance, who's been convicted of a crime in the United States. That's within the government's rights. deport a non-citizen, for instance, who's been convicted of a crime in the United States.
特朗普政府送到了萨尔瓦多的Seacot。有些人被送往那里是因为移民法官已经根据正常的联邦移民法认为这些人属于驱逐对象。政府当然可以驱逐一个非公民，例如，在美国被判有罪的人。这在政府的权利范围内。例如，驱逐一个在美国被判有罪的非公民。
That's within the government's rights. But a big number of these people sent to CCOT were only sent there because Trump designated them alien enemies under the Alien Enemies Act. Remember, Trump's claim is that these people in this group are part of a vicious criminal gang, TDA, and they're part of this predatory incursion upon the United States. But a recent investigation by the media outlet ProPublica found that only 32 of the 238 Venezuelans who had been sent there already had been convicted of crimes.
这在政府的权利范围内。但这些被送到CCOT的人中，有很大一部分仅仅是因为特朗普根据《外籍敌侨法》将他们指定为外籍敌侨才被送往那里的。记住，特朗普的主张是，这群人中的这些人是一个邪恶犯罪团伙TDA的一部分，他们是对美国掠夺性入侵的一部分。但媒体ProPublica最近的一项调查发现，在已经被送往那里的238名委内瑞拉人中，只有32人此前曾被判有罪。
And most of those crimes were for nonviolent offenses like shoplifting or traffic violations. So the entire Trump administration strategy so far seems to have been to rush out a group of Venezuelan nationals based on dubious claims about their clothes or their tattoos that they are wearing, sending them out of the country before any court really had a real opportunity to review their claims because, well well basically just Trump's plain assertion that they were members of TDA and that's just one question now can Trump do this can they just disappear people in the middle of the night on the accusation that they're enemy aliens right and the position of the Department of Homeland Security has been, well, due process means
而这些罪行大多是轻微的非暴力犯罪，如入店行窃或交通违规。因此，特朗普政府到目前为止的整个策略似乎是，基于关于他们衣服或纹身的虚假主张，匆忙将一群委内瑞拉国民送出国外，在任何法院真正有机会审查他们的主张之前，因为，嗯，基本上只是特朗普断言他们是TDA成员，现在有一个问题，特朗普能这样做吗？他们能仅仅因为被指控为敌国侨民就在深夜让人们消失吗？对，国土安全部的立场一直是，嗯，正当程序意味着
you get 12 to 24 hours to challenge your deportation. That's enough, right? You know, you look online, find a lawyer who's good at challenging an unprecedented use of the Alien Enemies Act. Yeah, I'm sure they will define them within 12 hours. Insane. Yeah, it's crazy. And then there's another question, how much process is required before these people are
你有12到24小时来挑战你的驱逐。这就够了，对吧？你知道，你在网上查一下，找一个擅长挑战前所未有的《外籍敌侨法》用法的律师。是的，我敢肯定他们会在12小时内找到他们。疯了。是的，这太疯狂了。然后还有另一个问题，在这些人被
deported? The Trump administration's argument had been that, well, if you're a member of TDA because we say so, then we can deport you with no hearing at all. Now, the Supreme Court has already squarely rejected that argument saying that's ridiculous. You get some process. Then there's a different question. Even if you have an Alien Enemies Act proclamation, does that mean you can send non-citizens to a foreign prison indefinitely?
驱逐之前需要多少程序？特朗普政府的论点是，嗯，如果你是TDA成员，因为我们这么说，那么我们就可以在没有任何听证的情况下驱逐你。现在，最高法院已经直接驳回了这一论点，称这太荒谬了。你必须获得一些程序。然后有一个不同的问题。即使你有《外籍敌侨法》公告，这是否意味着你可以无限期地将非公民送往外国监狱？
In World War II, most of these alien enemies were just deported. They were just expelled from the United States. They weren't sent to a mega prison. And then there's this separate objection of sending people not just to any prison, but this incredibly horrible, abusive supermax prison called ZCOT. After all, the United States is a party to an important international treaty, and that's the Convention Against Torture and other cruel and inhuman or degrading treatments or punishments. We are obligated to treat people even within our custody, no
在二战中，这些外籍敌侨大多只是被驱逐出境。他们只是被逐出美国。他们没有被送往超级监狱。然后还有一个单独的反对意见，即不仅把人送到任何监狱，而是送到这个极其可怕、虐待性的超级监狱，称为ZCOT。毕竟，美国是一个重要国际条约的缔约国，那就是《禁止酷刑和其他残忍、不人道或有辱人格的待遇或处罚公约》。我们有义务即使在我们的拘留中也要以人道条件对待人们，无论
matter what they've done to humane conditions. It would seem like at least a question of whether we're complying with our treaty obligations if we're sending people to this place. Absolutely, and paying for it. Yeah. So you mentioned that the Supreme Court hasn't weighed in on whether or not it's actually possible
他们做了什么。如果我们把人送到这个地方，这似乎至少是一个我们是否遵守条约义务的问题。绝对是，而且还要为此买单。是的。所以你提到最高法院还没有权衡特朗普是否真的可能
for Trump to use alien enemies acting this way, but has any court weighed in on this? Well, at least three federal district court judges, that's trial level court judges, have issued rulings that Trump can't rely on the Alien Enemies Act to deport non-citizens. But there is one judge, a Trump appointee in Pennsylvania, that said, well, maybe Trump can do this.
以这种方式使用《外籍敌侨法》，但有任何法院权衡过这个问题吗？嗯，至少有三位联邦地区法院法官，也就是初审法院法官，已经发布裁决称特朗普不能依赖《外籍敌侨法》来驱逐非公民。但有一位法官，一位宾夕法尼亚州的特朗普任命者，他说，嗯，也许特朗普可以这样做。
Okay. What is his argument there? Well, the judge found that it was enough that when the Trump administration declared that TDA was a foreign terrorist organization, What is his argument there? Well, the judge found that it was enough that when the Trump administration declared that TDA was a foreign terrorist organization, that that would qualify for them being this kind of terrible organization
好的。他那里的论点是什么？嗯，法官认为，当特朗普政府宣布TDA是一个外国恐怖组织时，这就足够了，他那里的论点是什么？嗯，法官认为，当特朗普政府宣布TDA是一个外国恐怖组织时，这就足以使他们成为这种可怕的组织，
that could lead to an Alien Enemies Act proclamation. The fact that TDA isn't a foreign country isn't a problem, said this judge, because the proclamation asserted that TDA was working with the Maduro regime in Venezuela. So remember that the Alien Enemies Act applies either when there's a declared war, declared by Congress, or any invasion or predatory incursion by a foreign government. And here's where things get kind of murky, right?
这可能导致《外籍敌侨法》公告。TDA不是一个外国这一事实不是问题，这位法官说，因为公告断言TDA正在与委内瑞拉的马杜罗政权合作。所以记住，《外籍敌侨法》适用于国会宣战，或外国政府的任何入侵或掠夺性入侵。这就是事情变得有点模糊的地方，对吧？
Because in our constitutional traditions, in foreign relations, there's generally a preference to defer to the president's judgment in times of war and foreign affairs issues, right? But the question is, is this really that kind of exercise of a president's discretion? Well, this one particular judge said, yeah, it is. And it's not for us to second guess what the Trump administration is doing,
因为在我们的宪法传统中，在外交关系中，通常倾向于在战争和外交事务问题上尊重总统的判断，对吧？但问题是，这真的是那种总统自由裁量权的行使吗？嗯，这位特定的法官说，是的，它是。我们不应该去质疑特朗普政府正在做什么，
so they can use the Alien Enemies Act that way. It kind of sounds like, well, if the president says so, it's so. That is not a conclusion that we should sit well with, because it sounds kind of terrifying. Whatever Trump says goes. Absolutely. That is very terrifying for any president to have that power. Well, that's right.
所以他们可以那样使用《外籍敌侨法》。这听起来有点像，嗯，如果总统这么说，那就是这样。这不是我们应该感到舒服的结论，因为它听起来有点可怕。无论特朗普说什么就是什么。绝对是。对于任何总统拥有这种权力来说，这都是非常可怕的。嗯，那是对的。
And in fact, it's much more persuasive to look at some of the other cases in which other federal district court judges said, I don't think the president can use the alien enemies that act this way. So in one of those cases, Judge Alvin Hellerstein began his opinion by saying this. More than 200 aliens were removed from this country
事实上，看看其他一些联邦地区法院法官说“我不认为总统可以以这种方式使用《外籍敌侨法》”的案件会更有说服力。所以在其中一个案件中，阿尔文·赫勒斯坦法官在意见书的开头这样写道。超过200名外籍人士被从这个国家移走
to El Salvador's terrorism confinement center with faint hope of process or return. They are there to remain indefinitely in a notoriously evil jail, unable to communicate with counsel, family or friends. So that really does give you a sense that, you know, there are judges here. I don't know how long they can be sort of a bulwark for the rest of our constitutional order. Judges who are sounding the alarm, this should not be happening. The Trump administration should not be using the law in this way. And then maybe the worst case of all is the case of Kilmar Abrego Garcia. So let's talk
到萨尔瓦多的恐怖主义监禁中心，几乎没有程序或返回的希望。他们被无限期地关押在一个臭名昭著的邪恶监狱里，无法与律师、家人或朋友交流。所以这确实让你感觉到，你知道，这里有法官。我不知道他们还能在多大程度上成为我们宪法秩序其余部分的堡垒。法官们正在敲响警钟，这不应该发生。特朗普政府不应该以这种方式使用法律。然后也许最糟糕的案件是基尔马·阿布雷戈·加西亚的案件。所以让我们谈谈
about him. Yeah, please. So, Abrego Garcia, who lives in Maryland, entered the United States in 2011. So he's fleeing gang violence from his native El Salvador. He meets and marries a US citizen. They have a child who's also a US citizen. Now in 2019, he's waiting outside of a Home Depot looking for work with a group of other men.
关于他。是的，请。所以，住在马里兰州的阿布雷戈·加西亚于2011年进入美国。所以他是在逃离家乡萨尔瓦多的帮派暴力。他遇到并娶了一位美国公民。他们有一个孩子，也是美国公民。现在在2019年，他正站在一家家得宝（Home Depot）外面，和一群其他人一起找工作。
He doesn't really know very well. The police arrive, they handcuff all the men. He never figures out why. He's never charged with a crime, but when they look up his status, they see he's undocumented and Abrego Garcia is transferred to an ICE detention facility. And the only information ICE provides about why Abrego Garcia could be a danger, this is in 2019, is that they say he's wearing a Chicago Bulls hat and a hoodie, and a confidential informant
他不太了解他们。警察到达，给所有男人戴上手铐。他永远不知道为什么。他从未被指控犯罪，但当他们查看他的身份时，他们发现他是无证件的，阿布雷戈·加西亚被转移到移民及海关执法局（ICE）的拘留设施。而ICE提供的关于为什么阿布雷戈·加西亚可能构成危险的唯一信息，这是在2019年，是他们说他戴着芝加哥公牛队的帽子和连帽衫，并且一名线人
had purportedly advised them that he's a member of the MS-13 criminal gang. Now, his lawyers at the time asked to speak to the police officer who logged this information to figure out where this come from, but then they learned that the officer has been suspended. Anyway, Abrego Garcia has always said he is not a member of any gang whatsoever.
据称告知他们他是MS-13犯罪团伙的成员。现在，他当时的律师要求与记录此信息的警官交谈，以弄清楚这是从哪里来的，但后来他们得知该警官已被停职。无论如何，阿布雷戈·加西亚一直说他根本不是任何帮派的成员。
And then he applies for asylum. And in October of 2019, maybe this is the key point of his story, an immigration judge agrees that Abrego Garcia faces persecution by gangs in El Salvador. That's why he had left. His family had faced threats by gangs about their family business. He's not allowed to be deported. So you have here a legal decision by an immigration judge agreeing that Abrego Garcia has a legal right to stay in the United States. ICE doesn't
然后他申请庇护。2019年10月，也许这是他故事的关键点，一位移民法官同意阿布雷戈·加西亚在萨尔瓦多面临帮派迫害。这就是他离开的原因。他的家人曾面临帮派对其家族企业的威胁。他不被允许被驱逐。所以你在这里有一个移民法官的法律决定，同意阿布雷戈·加西亚有留在美国的合法权利。ICE甚至没有
even appeal the decision. He gets released from custody, he goes home, and he has no criminal history after that, nothing of any sort. And he's supposed to have a mandatory yearly check in with ICE, and he complies each time. Then Trump is elected president. In March 12th of this year, Abrego Garcia is driving home from work. He's a sheet metal apprentice in Baltimore. And then he's pulled over by ICE officers. They take him away. And in the car with him is his five year old son. So his wife is called to go pick up their kid. She briefly sees a Briego Garcia and that's the very last time she sees him in person. She tried frantically to find him, but ICE keeps moving him from place to place until finally on March 16th.
对该决定提出上诉。他被释放出拘留所，他回家了，此后没有任何犯罪记录，没有任何性质的记录。他应该每年向ICE进行强制性报到，并且他每次都遵守。然后特朗普当选总统。今年3月12日，阿布雷戈·加西亚正开车下班回家。他是巴尔的摩的一名钣金学徒。然后他被ICE官员拦下。他们带走了他。和他在一起的车里还有他五岁的儿子。所以他的妻子被叫去接他们的孩子。她短暂地见到了阿布雷戈·加西亚，那是她最后一次亲自见到他。她疯狂地试图找到他，但ICE不断地把他从一个地方转移到另一个地方，直到最后在3月16日。
This is just days after he's stopped by ICE. She sees a news article of supposed gang members sent to Seacot, and she recognizes her husband. She files a lawsuit to secure his return. And on April 4th, a federal district judge ordered the government to return him to the United States. Remember, an immigration judge had already decided in 2019 that the government could not deport Abrego Garcia. This was a mistake. In fact, this is a case where the Trump administration actually acknowledges that they made a
这就在他被ICE拦下几天后。她看到了一篇关于据称被送往Seacot的帮派成员的新闻文章，她认出了她的丈夫。她提起诉讼以确保他回来。4月4日，一名联邦地区法官命令政府将他送回美国。记住，一位移民法官已经在2019年决定政府不能驱逐阿布雷戈·加西亚。这是一个错误。事实上，这是一个特朗普政府实际上承认他们犯了
mistake. When the judge asked the government's lawyer why was he sent there, the lawyer replies, I don't know. That information has not been given to me. I don't know. But shouldn't that resolve the case and lead to him being brought back? Yeah, normally the conventional answer is yes. In this case, the government admits that they made a mistake. So the next logical step would be they bring him back. So you think it would resolve the case, but it doesn't. Because the government's position now is we made a mistake, but sorry, there's nothing we can do about it now. He's in El Salvador. It's out of our hands. And the government then appeals the district court's
错误的案件。当法官问政府律师他为什么被送到那里时，律师回答说，我不知道。该信息没有提供给我。我不知道。但这不应该解决案件并导致他被带回来吗？是的，通常传统的答案是肯定的。在这个案件中，政府承认他们犯了一个错误。所以下一个合乎逻辑的步骤应该是他们把他带回来。所以你认为这会解决案件，但并没有。因为政府现在的立场是，我们犯了一个错误，但抱歉，我们现在无能为力。他在萨尔瓦多。这超出了我们的控制范围。然后政府对地区法院的
order to return to Abrego Garcia. And that eventually goes up to the Supreme Court as another emergency matter. And on April 10, the Supreme Court upholds the district court's decision to demand a Briego-Garcia's return. The court says that the lower court order properly requires the government to facilitate a Briego-Garcia's release from custody in El Salvador. So Justice Sotomayor writes a separate opinion to point out, look, this isn't someone else's problem. This isn't a Briego-Garcia's problem. This isn't a Abrego Garcia's problem. This is an everyone problem. Because if the government can mistakenly send a non-citizen
返回阿布雷戈·加西亚的命令提出上诉。这最终作为另一个紧急事项上诉到最高法院。4月10日，最高法院维持了地区法院要求阿布雷戈·加西亚返回的决定。法院表示，下级法院的命令适当地要求政府促进阿布雷戈·加西亚从萨尔瓦多的拘留中获释。所以索托马约尔法官写了一份单独的意见书指出，看，这不是别人的问题。这不是阿布雷戈·加西亚的问题。这不是阿布雷戈·加西亚的问题。这是一个所有人的问题。因为如果政府可以错误地将一名非公民
to a third country and say, there's nothing we can do about it, they can so-called mistakenly send anybody, even a US citizen, she says, and dump them in another country without any legal consequence, even if a court tries to intervene. So Sotomayor's point, and this is an important one, is that she's really saying this is kind
送到第三国并说，我们对此无能为力，他们可以所谓错误地送走任何人，甚至是美国公民，她说，并把他们扔到另一个国家而没有任何法律后果，即使法院试图干预。所以索托马约尔的观点，这是一个重要的观点，是她真的在说这是一种
of the end of the rule of law if we allow this. No one is going to be safe from an administration's completely arbitrary and lawless decisions if we allow this to happen. Yeah, that makes sense to me. And so what happened to him? Well, that's the bizarre part of it. It's June and he's still there. So remember the court order that the Supreme Court is referring to says that the government
法治的终结，如果我们允许这种情况发生。如果我们允许这种情况发生，没有人会免受政府完全任意和无法无天的决定的影响。是的，这对我来说很有道理。那么他发生了什么事？嗯，那是其中最离奇的部分。现在是六月，他还在那里。所以记住最高法院提到的法院命令说，政府
is supposed to do everything it can to facilitate his return. I don't know, what's your sense of the word facilitate? I mean, like use all available ability and you know, like, I don't know, they don't know. What's your sense of the word facilitate? I mean, like, you use all available ability and, you know, like, I don't know, they don't maybe they don't work on weekends, but at least they, they do everything they can to get him back. Yeah, well, the government and Rego Garcia's lawyers are really initially fighting over the word facilitate. What does it mean to facilitate?
应该尽其所能促进他的返回。我不知道，你对“促进”这个词有什么感觉？我的意思是，就像使用所有可用的能力，你知道，就像，我不知道，他们不知道。你对“促进”这个词有什么感觉？我的意思是，就像，你使用所有可用的能力，你知道，就像，我不知道，他们不，也许他们周末不工作，但至少他们，他们尽其所能让他回来。是的，好吧，政府和阿布雷戈·加西亚的律师最初确实在为“促进”这个词争论。促进意味着什么？
Do they just check in on him? Does that mean put him on a plane immediately? Right. Maybe just find out where he is. The case actually continues to drag out in court months after Abrego Garcia was taken away by ICE officers, which the government admits was a mistake. So in other words, there is in fact actually
他们只是去看看他吗？这是否意味着立即把他送上飞机？对。也许只是找出他在哪里。案件实际上在阿布雷戈·加西亚被ICE官员带走几个月后继续在法庭上拖延，政府承认这是一个错误。换句话说，事实上确实
no lawful basis for the government to have taken Abreger Garcia out of the United States to another country. No legal basis to continue to have him be held there and not return him back to the United States where he has a right to be. Is there any consequence to that? That they're not like the Trump administration isn't sort of adhering to a Supreme Court order?
没有法律依据让政府把阿布雷戈·加西亚从美国带到另一个国家。没有法律依据继续让他被关押在那里，而不把他送回他有权待的美国。这有什么后果吗？他们不是像特朗普政府没有遵守最高法院的命令吗？
Well, that's the uncomfortable part here. It is kind of the case that the Trump administration is violating court orders Well, there's a couple of different ways this is happening Not just in a Brieger Garcia's case because they're not returning him There's also the April 7th order in one of the other alien enemies cases where the government was told don't remove people Without a notice and an opportunity to challenge their designation as alien enemies. But then they continued to do that. That's why there was that middle of the night order.
嗯，这是这里令人不舒服的部分。特朗普政府违反法院命令确实是这种情况。嗯，这有几种不同的发生方式。不仅仅是在阿布雷戈·加西亚的案件中，因为他们没有送回他。在其他外籍敌侨案件之一中，还有4月7日的命令，政府被告知不要在没有通知和机会挑战他们作为外籍敌侨的指定的情况下移走人员。但后来他们继续这样做。这就是为什么会有那个深夜命令。
So there are at least two instances here where the government is being told by the court, do something. And the government's like, maybe now we don't have to do that right now. So if we're now living in a world where we can't rely on the executive branch following court orders, we're in a very, very bad place. None of this is normal, and we shouldn't allow it to become normal. So these are not problems of other people. I mean, I think that's one of the strange things about what's happened so far this year.
所以这里至少有两个例子，政府被法院告知，做某事。而政府就像，也许现在我们不必现在就做。所以如果我们现在生活在一个我们不能依赖行政部门遵守法院命令的世界里，我们处于一个非常、非常糟糕的境地。这一切都不正常，我们不应该允许它变得正常。所以这些不是别人的问题。我的意思是，我认为这是今年到目前为止发生的事情中奇怪的事情之一。
It's not as if we live in a dual legal system where some people are being treated horribly and then the rest of us kind of go on and live their lives. If the government can make arbitrary decisions about some people, it can make arbitrary decisions about anybody. It can make arbitrary decisions not just about your liberty, it could make arbitrary decisions about your livelihood or your bank account or the way the economy is gonna be run or anything. I mean, the rule of law is basically an expectation that there's an order to things. And if there is no rule of law,
这并不是说我们生活在一个双重法律体系中，一些人受到可怕的对待，然后我们其他人继续过着他们的生活。如果政府可以对一些人做出任意决定，它就可以对任何人做出任意决定。它不仅可以对你的自由做出任意决定，它还可以对你的生计或你的银行账户或经济运行方式或任何事情做出任意决定。我的意思是，法治基本上是一种对事物有秩序的期望。如果没有法治，
then you don't really know what's gonna happen on any particular day in any particular moment. Yeah, I mean, that's a terrifying way to live. That's like, the reason why people care about the constitution at all is because it's this 200 year old, old oldest still in force rulebook of how a country is run and if you don't do those things then it's sort of meaningless like the what everything that makes us special is out the window. Yeah, it's basically like it's like a
那么你真的不知道在任何特定的一天、任何特定的时刻会发生什么。是的，我的意思是，那是一种可怕的生活方式。那就像，人们关心宪法的全部原因是因为它是这本200年历史的、仍然有效的国家运行规则手册，如果你不遵守这些事情，那么它就有点毫无意义，就像所有让我们特别的东西都从窗户飞走了。是的，它基本上就像它就像一个
You know a social contract. It's a code of honor. It's basically like a, it's like a, you know, a social contract. It's a code of honor. It's an honor system we've agreed to live by. And that's pretty much all the courts have, right? Because if the courts just say do this and the Trump administration says no, then there's nothing else we can do, right? I mean, we all sort of depend on the judiciary being respected in terms of their judgments because just because of their legitimacy. But if you have another branch of government
你知道社会契约。它是一部荣誉准则。它基本上就像一个，它就像一个，你知道，社会契约。它是一部荣誉准则。这是我们同意遵守的荣誉体系。而这基本上就是法院所拥有的全部，对吧？因为如果法院只是说做这个，而特朗普政府说不，那么我们就没有其他办法了，对吧？我的意思是，我们都依赖司法机构在他们的判断方面受到尊重，仅仅因为他们的合法性。但如果你有另一个政府部门
that starts to ignore them, then there's really no telling what happens from here. It's a terrifying world. Yeah. Now, finally, I want to bring up one more aspect of the Alien Enemies Act. Kind of even reluctant to bring it up, but let's do it. Okay.
开始忽视他们，那么从这里开始真的不知道会发生什么。这是一个可怕的世界。是的。现在，最后，我想提出《外籍敌侨法》的另一个方面。甚至有点不情愿提出来，但让我们做吧。好的。
Almost all of the public attention to the Alien Enemies Act is focused on its primary provision that's 50 USC 21. That's the part that gives the President of the United States the power to declare that some group of people can be considered alien enemies. But here's another provision 50 US 23. And Roman, why don't we have you read it. After any such proclamation has been made, the several courts of the United States are
几乎所有公众对《外籍敌侨法》的关注都集中在其主要条款上，即美国法典第50卷第21条。那是赋予美国总统权力宣布某些群体可以被视为外籍敌侨的部分。但这里有另一个条款，美国法典第50卷第23条。罗曼，为什么不让你读一下。在做出任何此类公告后，美国的几个法院
authorized upon complaint against any alien enemy resident to the danger of the public peace or safety, and contrary to the tenor or intent of such proclamation, to cause such alien to be duly apprehended and conveyed before such court, judge, or justice, and after a full examination and hearing on such complaint and sufficient cause appearing, to order such alien to be removed out of the territory of the United States, or to give sureties for his good behavior or to be otherwise restrained." Okay, so that is a mouthful. What exactly does that mean?
被授权在收到针对任何对公共和平或安全构成危险，且违反此类公告的宗旨或意图的居住外籍敌侨的投诉后，促使该外籍人士被正式逮捕并传唤到此类法院、法官或司法官面前，并在对此类投诉进行全面审查和听证，且出现充分理由后，命令将该外籍人士移出美国领土，或提供其良好行为的担保，或以其他方式受到限制。”好的，所以那是一大段话。那到底是什么意思？
So this provision 23, it sounds like it gives federal courts authority over alien enemy cases directly, not like the ones we've talked about earlier today. Whenever there is what the provision calls a complaint. Well that's kind of weird because the president doesn't file a complaint under the act. He just makes a proclamation and the executive branch is just set into motion, which is exactly what we've seen. Well, it turns out that a federal appeals court in 1946 said that section 23 means that the Alien Enemies Act applies when a citizen files a complaint
所以这个第23条，听起来它直接赋予联邦法院对外籍敌侨案件的管辖权，不像我们今天早些时候谈论的那些。每当有该条款所称的“投诉”时。嗯，这有点奇怪，因为总统并没有根据该法案提交投诉。他只是发布公告，行政部门就启动了，这正是我们所看到的。嗯，事实证明，1946年的一家联邦上诉法院表示，第23条意味着当公民提交投诉时，《外籍敌侨法》适用
that a person is an enemy alien. So the Brennan Center, a nonpartisan legal and policy institute, points out that this appears to be a private enforcement mechanism for the Alien Enemies Act. So this is why I'm even loathe to bring this up. But anyway, like someone might say, hey, I think my neighbor is an alien enemy. I'm going to file a legal complaint against them. So to be clear, there don't appear to be any historical cases where private individuals have done this. So maybe no one ever has. And I hope the anti-immigration groups are not listening to this, but none of these groups have ever raised this possibility. So let's just hope that people aren't paying
某人是敌国侨民。所以布伦南中心，一个无党派的法律和政策研究所，指出这似乎是《外籍敌侨法》的一种私人执行机制。所以这就是为什么我甚至不想提这个。但无论如何，就像有人可能会说，嘿，我认为我的邻居是外籍敌侨。我要对他们提起法律投诉。所以要明确的是，似乎没有任何历史案例表明私人个人这样做过。所以也许从来没有人这样做过。我希望反移民团体没有在听这个，但这些团体中没有一个曾经提出过这种可能性。所以让我们只希望人们没有注意
attention to this because it raises the horrible, horrible possibility of mass deportation vigilantes. If this section actually does allow citizens to file complaints, you can imagine the kind of havoc it creates. I mean, a good parallel is from what's happened after the demise of abortion rights. You might remember SB 8 in Texas, where you could just file a complaint against somebody in court.
到这一点，因为它提出了大规模驱逐治安维持者的可怕、可怕的可能性。如果这一节确实允许公民提交投诉，你可以想象它造成的破坏。我的意思是，一个很好的平行案例是堕胎权终结后发生的事情。你可能记得德克萨斯州的SB 8，在那里你可以在法庭上对某人提起投诉。
You could sue somebody if you thought that they were engaged in what Texas considers an illegal abortion. There's also the, historically, America has a long tradition of vigilantism. So none of this sounds good, but it is buried in there, and let's just hope it stays buried in there.
如果你认为某人参与了德克萨斯州认为的非法堕胎，你可以起诉某人。还有，历史上，美国有悠久的治安维持传统。所以这一切听起来都不好，但它埋在里面，让我们只希望它保持埋在里面。
I mean, what is the good of you bringing it up now? If we can't stop it? Like if you're, if you're coming back, Kyle Reese coming back from the future and trying to stop it, like why come back and tell us this if we can't stop it? Is there a way to stop it? I'm not sure that there's a way to stop it. There have been repeated attempts to repeal the Alien Enemies Act wholesale, which have not succeeded thus far.
我的意思是，你现在提出来有什么好处？如果我们不能阻止它？就像如果你是，如果你是凯尔·里斯从未来回来试图阻止它，就像为什么回来告诉我们这个，如果我们不能阻止它？有什么办法可以阻止它吗？我不确定有什么办法可以阻止它。已经有多次尝试全面废除《外籍敌侨法》，但到目前为止都没有成功。
But it's a way to draw attention to, you know, we've had this act around for a long time giving incredible authority, not just to the president, but apparently to normal people too, but in acts of extreme urgency in wartime. And I guess it's to remind people it's not supposed to be used this way as some sort of tool of vengeance, racism, or xenophobia in ordinary times. Yeah, yeah. And all the other parts, people recognize those like the part, the sedition part of the act and stuff like this, were eliminated
但这是一种引起注意的方式，你知道，我们有这个法案很长时间了，赋予了令人难以置信的权力，不仅给总统，显然也给普通人，但在战时的极端紧急情况下。我想这是为了提醒人们，它不应该在平时被用作某种报复、种族主义或仇外心理的工具。是的，是的。所有其他部分，人们认识到那些，像法案的煽动部分之类的东西，被消除了
because common sense prevailed over the last couple hundred years. But not in this case, not with this act. No, not at all. This is sobering stuff. I'm glad that we're back to talk about it. I really appreciate you coming on and continuing the show with me.
因为常识在过去几百年里占了上风。但在这个案件中不是，不是这个法案。不，一点也不。这是发人深省的事情。我很高兴我们回来谈论它。我真的很感谢你来并继续和我一起做这个节目。
Yeah, thanks, Rue. So in addition to the What Trump Can Teach Us About Con Law that we're restarting as a monthly series, we've decided that as our book club to sort of take the place of the power broker, we're going to have the U.S. Constitution be our book. That's the thing that we are going to cover once a month with Elizabeth, and we're going to go step by step through the Constitution. Instead of a 1,200 page book, we're going to do like a 7,500 word document instead. That's maybe about five or six pages long.
是的，谢谢，鲁。所以除了我们作为月度系列重新开始的《特朗普能教我们什么关于宪法法》，我们决定作为我们的读书俱乐部来代替《权力掮客》，我们将把美国宪法作为我们的书。这就是我们将每月与伊丽莎白一起涵盖的内容，我们将一步一步地学习宪法。而不是一本1200页的书，我们将做一份大约7500字的文件。那大约有五六页长。
Right, right. The best book club ever. You don't have to pretend that you read it, but you really didn't. So yeah, starting in July, every month we're going to cover sort of a what Trump can teach us about con law, something that's happened in current events. And then we're going to also have a book club covering section by section, maybe a few words at a time. And we'll be joined by all kinds of guests who care about these things and in various
对，对。有史以来最好的读书俱乐部。你不必假装你读了它，但你真的没有。所以是的，从七月开始，每个月我们将涵盖某种关于特朗普能教我们什么关于宪法法，时事中发生的事情。然后我们还将有一个读书俱乐部，逐节涵盖，也许一次几个字。我们将有各种各样关心这些事情的嘉宾加入我们，以各种
ways. We'll release a schedule so you can do the reading ahead of time if you want to. The reading might be 30 or 40 words, actually. Literally. if you want to, but the reading might be 30 or 40 words, actually. Literally. And we're going to treat the Constitution like in a historical context, in a present day consequences context, maybe even just as the text itself,
方式。我们将发布一个时间表，这样如果你愿意，你可以提前阅读。阅读可能实际上是30或40个字。字面上。如果你愿意，但阅读可能实际上是30或40个字。字面上。我们将把宪法视为历史背景，在当今后果背景下，也许甚至只是作为文本本身，
like this one's hard to read. Treat it like a real book club, not just about the history import of everything, but talk about every little aspect of it that strikes you when you read it as a reader and as a citizen or as a denizen of the United States, which the Constitution does apply to all denizens, not citizens. That's an important thing to recognize.
就像这个很难读。把它当作一个真正的读书俱乐部，不仅仅是关于一切的历史重要性，而是谈论当你作为读者和公民，或者作为美国的居民阅读它时，每一个让你印象深刻的小方面，宪法确实适用于所有居民，而不是公民。这是一个需要认识到的重要事情。
Exactly. So anything else that you want to mention with it like you're excited about or want to? Yeah, I mean, I think that you know, we are definitely in some dark times but I think the book club is a way to kind of be hopeful and to think about a document that deserve to survive and to prop up our Constitutional Republic for some time longer and part of that is to feel hopeful that are, there's a structure there and there's a purpose and an intention behind the document and the words. And just by discussing
完全正确。所以还有什么你想提到的，你感到兴奋或想？是的，我的意思是，我认为你知道，我们绝对处于一些黑暗时期，但我认为读书俱乐部是一种充满希望的方式，去思考一份值得生存并支撑我们宪政共和国更长时间的文件，其中一部分是感到希望，那里有一个结构，文件和文字背后有一个目的和意图。仅仅通过讨论
it, people can feel better informed and hopefully optimistic. Yeah. So when we first started what Trump can do about common law in 2017, a lot of what I was looking for when I was like out to you was, I want to understand the Constitution and constitutional law more because everyone was invoking constitutional law. Oh, Trump can't do this because X or X states that Trump can't do this or whatever it is. We're entering a stranger territory here, a darker territory here, where there are laws and there are judgments and the Trump administration is simply not following them.
它，人们可以感到更知情，并希望乐观。是的。所以当我们2017年第一次开始《特朗普能教我们什么关于宪法法》时，当我联系你时，我寻找的很多东西是，我想更多地了解宪法和宪法法，因为每个人都在援引宪法法。哦，特朗普不能这样做，因为X或X规定特朗普不能这样做，或者无论它是什么。我们正在进入一个更陌生、更黑暗的领域，那里有法律，有判决，而特朗普政府根本不遵守它们。
And that comfort I had back, you know, like eight years ago, is it's sort of different now. Like where I was resting on the constitution to sort of like, you know, to wrap a warm blanket around myself, using the constitution and say, now we can be warm and protected. Now it feels like a different world in which it really isn't the protection it once was
而我八年前拥有的那种安慰，现在有点不同了。就像我过去依靠宪法来，你知道，给自己裹上一条温暖的毯子，使用宪法并说，现在我们可以温暖并受到保护。现在感觉像是一个不同的世界，它真的不再是曾经的保护了
because of just not following the law and not following the constitution. So like, is it futile to like point to the constitution? I mean, like we used to just like, I just remember like 2017, we'd go, a monuments clause, a monuments clause, he's filing the monuments clause as if it mattered. And now we've learned that it kind of doesn't matter.
因为只是不遵守法律，不遵守宪法。所以，指向宪法是徒劳的吗？我的意思是，我们过去只是，我记得2017年，我们会说，薪酬条款，薪酬条款，他违反了薪酬条款，好像这很重要。现在我们已经了解到它有点不重要。
And so why bother? Like why bother schooling ourselves in sort of the fundamental rule book of the nation if the rules aren't followed? I think because this time the Constitution is not a warm blanket for us. We have to provide the support. If we want to believe in the system that we have been living in prior to Trump and Trumpism, we have to really understand why these words take on meaning.
所以为什么要费心呢？如果我们不遵守规则，为什么要费心去学习国家的根本规则手册呢？我认为因为这一次宪法不是我们温暖的毯子。我们必须提供支持。如果我们想相信我们在特朗普和特朗普主义之前一直生活在其中的体系，我们必须真正理解为什么这些词具有意义。
They take on meaning through practice and through sort of popular support and enforcement. And I think it's not just a set of rules that are out there that other people, you know, rushed to court and other courts do in some distant way far from my everyday life. It's actually really important to understand, hey, I mean, I get why we have this sort of, you know, community writ large commitment to this idea of a constitutional democracy. And I think so we're we've got to be the warm black and we have to be the support system to think about what's important here, because everything about the Constitution is, like I said, it's
它们通过实践和某种大众支持和执行而具有意义。我认为这不仅仅是一套存在于那里的规则，其他人（你知道）冲向法庭，其他法院以某种遥远的方式，远离我的日常生活。理解这一点实际上非常重要，嘿，我的意思是，我明白为什么我们对这种宪政民主理念有这种（你知道）广泛的社区承诺。所以我认为我们必须成为温暖的毯子，我们必须成为支持系统，去思考这里什么是重要的，因为关于宪法的一切，就像我说的，它是
an honor system, like we all have to agree that this is important and it's meaningful because if we don't, everything is a, the Constitution is a commitment we make on a day-to-day basis. And that's part of what thinking about it in a broad historical and sometimes fun way can achieve. Yeah, yeah. So the Constitution right now is not lending aid and comfort to us.
一个荣誉体系，就像我们所有人都必须同意这是重要的，它是有意义的，因为如果我们不这样做，一切都是，宪法是我们每天做出的承诺。这就是以广泛的历史和有时有趣的方式思考它所能实现的一部分。是的，是的。所以宪法现在没有给我们提供援助和安慰。
It is our time to rise up and lend aid and comfort to the Constitution so that this stuff continues on because I like our experiment of the United States. And so let's keep going with it. Yeah, exactly. So starting with our first episode will be about the preamble to the Constitution. And you can do it. It's just 52 words. It's so easy to read it ahead of time.
现在是我们站起来为宪法提供援助和安慰的时候了，这样这些东西才能继续下去，因为我喜欢我们的美国实验。所以让我们继续下去。是的，完全正确。所以从我们的第一集开始，将是关于宪法序言。你可以做到。它只有52个字。提前阅读它太容易了。
Even if you start the podcast, you can just pause it for a minute and then read it. And then we can start right there. And so that'll start in July every month. So I hope you join us for that. It's going to be very, very cool. So thank you so much, Elizabeth. I really, really appreciate it.
即使你开始播客，你也可以暂停一分钟，然后阅读它。然后我们可以从那里开始。所以这将从七月开始，每个月。所以我希望你加入我们。这将是非常、非常酷的。所以非常感谢你，伊丽莎白。我真的、真的很感激。
I'm so glad that we're going to continue on. That's going to be great. After a recording, the Trump administration returned Kilmar Abrego-Garcia to the United States on June 6th and criminally charged him with transporting undocumented migrants into the United States. Abrego-Garcia will now face those charges in federal court
我很高兴我们将继续下去。那会很棒的。录音后，特朗普政府于6月6日将基尔马·阿布雷戈-加西亚送回美国，并对他进行了刑事指控，指控他将无证移民运送到美国。阿布雷戈-加西亚现在将在联邦法院面对这些指控
as a criminal defendant. Theme music is provided by Doomtree Records, the Midwest hip hop collective. You can find out more about Doomtree Records, get merch, and learn about who's on tour at Doomtree.net. Additional music by Swan Real and Epidemic Sound. We are part of the SiriusXM Podcast family. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
作为刑事被告。主题音乐由中西部嘻哈团体Doomtree Records提供。你可以在Doomtree.net上了解更多关于Doomtree Records的信息，购买周边，并了解谁在巡演。Swan Real和Epidemic Sound提供额外音乐。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。